hey what's happening my name is samuel
leet and in this video i wanted to
actually
do a very special invitation and invite
you to a completely free
lease option agreement training session
where i'm going to be teaching you how
to
find secure and buy properties instead
of having to save up a deposit
and put down a big deposit on a house
how you can do it on a lease option
agreement
where you can acquire properties with
just a one pound
option fee now there is a catch and the
catch is that of course you're going to
pay legal fees
i mean most people i mean the reason
people want to buy properties
is because they want to get number one
they want to get rent
there's two reasons by the way number
one you want to get rent
every single month when you buy a
property it gives you cash flow it gives
you rent
and the second reason people want to buy
houses is because they go up in value
over time
if you buy a house for 100 grand and you
sit on it
chances are in 10 years time it could be
worth 200 000 pounds
historically properties tend to double
in value every 10 years
so people buy properties number one rent
number two they buy properties because
they want it to go up in value now
here's the thing
how much is it gonna cost you to buy a
house generally speaking
we're gonna have to pay 25 percent on
the
deposit you're gonna have to pay
stamp duty fees you're gonna have to pay
legal fees
you're probably talking absolute minimum
of thirty thousand pounds
assuming you buy a really cheap property
just to buy a house that might give you
two or three hundred pounds a month
profit
now that's okay that's not bad but how
long is it going to take you to save up
that 25 30 000 pound deposit
i mean the average that's that's a
year's salary
and unless you can live for free for a
year where is that going to come from
maybe you're going to inherit the money
great so you buy one house but how
how do you grow your portfolio and
that's the reason why most people
don't grow a property portfolio they
don't grow property portfolio because
they haven't got the money to keep
buying properties
i mean the average person is about 30
years old now
before they buy a house i mean geez i'm
not even 30 yet
and i've got millions and millions of
pounds worth of properties
so how have i done it when i started
from scratch and how
many of my students done it how do
people become
self-made successful property investors
when they aren't winning the lottery or
being inherited loads of money
and the answer is lease option
agreements
and you can do lease option agreements
on small houses on big houses
on pieces of land you can get just about
as creative as you want
with lease option agreements so how does
it work well it's very simple
lease option agreement is when you buy a
house now but you agree to pay for
it later so you might find a property
that's worth a hundred thousand pounds
you say hey
i'll buy it for a hundred thousand
pounds but i'll pay you in
ten years and in the next ten years
you benefit from the property as if you
owned it
you benefit from the rent and you
benefit from any capital appreciation
so it says if you bought it
it's as if you paid for it you're
benefiting exactly the same
but you didn't pay for it you paid a
one-pound option fee
and you secured it on an option so the
question is who
in their right mind would let you take
on their property
on a lease option agreement who would
let you do it and the answer is
tired landlords people that their houses
are empty
uh people that have inherited their
property and they don't need the money
now
people that are in negative equity where
they can't sell their houses because
their mortgages
are too high these types of individuals
and these types of sellers
will let you buy their property on a
lease option agreement
you can do it on land you can maybe find
a nice piece of land and you can say hey
look i'll buy it
on an option i'll buy it in 12 months
and then in that 12 months
you get planning permission and you push
the price of the land up
and then you buy it at the massively
reduced price
now on my lease option training i share
how to find these types of sellers
how to know how to negotiate with them
how to put forward your offer
also how it works how it's structured so
if you want to join me on the lease
option
101 webinar i'm going to leave in the
description
a link you can join me completely free
there's no catches
where i'm going to share everything
about lease option agreements
it's about a 90-minute webinar and
that's going to be on thursday
evening this week so get registered i
look forward to seeing you there
and i hope to help you build up a
property portfolio
like i have done and i'm you know i've
always vowed if i become successful
i'm going to hold my money with open
hands and a generous heart and i'm also
going to share freely
because most rich people hide away you
know most rich people let me tell you
this
it's very common knowledge every
everybody on the media and on the tv
all talk about buying houses sorry
buying cars now i'm paying for it later
you know buy zero percent finance dfs
sofa buy it now pay later it's very
normal
and that's what poor people do poor
people buy
liabilities and pay for them later but
by the time they come to pay for them
later
they've gone down in value and in the
meantime they've not profited they're
not giving them any rent
last time i checked a car doesn't pay
you any rent what rich people do
is they do that but just with properties
i mean you tell me what's more risky
buying a car
now and paying for it later when the car
is going to lose its value and not pay
you any money
or buying a property investment now and
paying for it later when the property
investment is going to go up
that's going to pay your rent this is a
complete no no brainer
nearly all property developers do this
most wealthy people
understand how this works this is very
very common knowledge lease option
agreements within
commercial property within business you
can buy a business now pay for it later
but they keep this from you when it
comes to residential property
because the system is not created for
the ordinary person like you and i
to get very very wealthy it's not
created for that however i'm going to be
sharing freely and openly all the
strategies
and i really can't wait to see you
succeed and you'll probably be with me
on this youtube channel on the other end
of the screen
sharing how you do it every single week
i have a winners on a wednesday
show where someone shares their success
of how they became financially free
from the strategies that i teach so if
you're wondering is this really possible
is it too good to be true or hey join
the club
you know there's many many many other
people that are succeeding with these
strategies so join the club it's
completely free
link in the description and i look
forward to seeing you on the other side
thanks